good morning believe nation today's
messages focus on you first over to you
Jada pinkett-smith you had to take care
of yourself in order to have the
alignment and the power to take care of
others at the capacity that we do
because it fills the well what what I
believe that I do take so much energy so
much work from heart spirit and
creativity that I had to be responsible
enough to take care of me because you
know what happens imbalance comes and
you know what happens I look to you well
and I say willow you've got to do this
because if you don't you you become I
start looking towards you I start making
you responsible for my happiness and a
lot of times you know we do we look to
our men we look to our husbands and our
boyfriends and we go you I've given all
this up for you and you've got to make
this right by me and you're supposed to
make me happy because we've lost our way
on how to make ourselves happy we lost
our way so what I had to do and what I
had to learn was how to get more balance
in over the years each year each day I
get more and more and more and more
imbalance more and more and more in
alignment and you know what I get more
and more happy and the very thing that I
thought would make you unhappy or make
Jaden unhappy or make daddy unhappy
actually is fulfilling for you guys as
well even though you might it might not
be a tangible reason but the more happy
I am in the more fulfilled I am it works
for the family and when I'm not it
doesn't it's really that simple I love
this message and I agree that a lot of
people expect their happiness to come
from others and we blame other people
for not
giving us the happiness that we need in
our lives and if I put that in an
entrepreneurial context a lot of times
we spend too much time focusing on
external factors blaming other people
for our dissatisfaction for where we are
not quite at yet in your in our
businesses if you're not happy with
where you're at right now if you have
not reached the goals that you want to
reach the way to break through is to
accept the responsibility and to not
blame other people for it it's a theme
that I've covered multiple times on the
channel and I get that it's hard because
the easy thing to do was to blame
somebody else to blame your parents at a
building the government or you know
blame your business partner who screwed
you over or blame somebody else the easy
thing is that blame somebody else is not
your fault that's the easy thing to do
but when you can realize that it's up to
you that the cavalry is not coming that
you need to accept that responsibility
for where you're at in your business
that if you're not as far long as you
want to be it's because you haven't done
the work yet or because your product or
service isn't valuable enough yet or you
haven't invested enough in yourself to
be that person yet and when you realize
that when you truly accept that
responsibility
two things happen the first is sadness
is maybe a bit of despair is
uncomfortableness because the fear
starts to creep in as to whether you
have the abilities to be that person
it's way easier to blame somebody else
but now that's on me I'm not being
successful because of me then you start
thinking do I have the ability to do it
can I do it can I be that person do I
have the skills do I want to put in the
work to actually become that person who
leads us business to success the second
part is it's empowering because once you
get through all of that realization that
it's scary and that's gonna be a lot of
hard work it's empowering because you
have an answer because at the end of
blame at the end of complaining there is
no answer the answer is just to blame
that person but you never make the
progress that you need to make or if you
understand that it's up to you that
you've accepted that responsibility then
yes it's gonna be a lot of hard work yes
you're gonna be putting in insane number
of hours to make yourself a better
leader a better entrepreneur a better
person but it's under your control and
that's empowering and that will let you
get to where you need to be and so if
you ever find yourself saying you can't
do something if you ever find yourself
blaming something or complaining about
something try to catch yourself
try to stop in that moment and realize
that this is not the correct action and
that you need to take accountability and
responsibility where you're at right now
and that you choose not to do that
whether it's in the best interest or not
and once you start making better choices
you'll start having better outcomes so
the question today today is how much do
you focus on you first leave in the
comments below I'm going to join the
discussion finally want to give a quick
shout out to mr. mo from mr. mo da ve
mr. mo thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book if you guys watching
if you want to change that a shadow in
the future video make sure to grab a
copy of the book and email in your
receipt so we can keep track thank you
guys again for watching have an amazing
day continue to believe or whatever your
one word is and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso and it's not an easy solution
Hayden Hayden